[Music]
heading into june it already looks like
everyone's decided on anime of the
season to no one's surprise spring's
been a fun season and a lot of it is due
to the variety of great hits that we've
gotten so without further ado let me
tour you through the sights and sounds
of spring 2022 and talk about what i
think are the best new anime we've
gotten so far
[Music]
bubble has two things going for it the
all-star cast filling out the production
team is the first one the second is the
production quality as expected from an
anime movie a beautiful world brought to
life through its vibrant soundtrack and
astonishing art quality one thing i
didn't know until watching it was how
this movie is inspired by the little
mermaid yet i also find itself going
down the route of various anime movies
look there's weathering with you weaved
into this tale of learning to be human
and something like that i feel that the
talents of the production team showed
especially in the presentation aspect of
it but i must concede that the plot is
just decent possible but not something
mind-blowing like what we've seen from
urobuchi still that doesn't mean i
didn't like the movie it's a good and
fulfilling way to pass the time and for
some context when i used urobuchi's name
i was talking masterpieces like fate
zero psychopass or madoka magicka taken
in a vacuum bubble is still a great
touching movie that we can recommend to
the family
released not too long ago vampire in the
garden tells of a tale we're probably
familiar with at this point humans
hiding in city walls fearful of the
monsters that lie beyond however those
walls do little in preventing the
idealistic momo and the vampire queen
from having their chance encounter
members of two conflicting species bound
by their desires for change embark on a
journey to find eden it's an engaging
story that's well paced closing at just
five episodes i mean i'd even consider
this a movie instead of a full anime
series and i feel like it's intended to
be watched as such filled with
characters that you can't help but
empathize and root for as well as an
enchanting world brought to life by the
efforts of studio wit vampire in the
garden is a relatively short watch that
will leave you feeling satisfied vampire
in the garden's not the perfect show nor
is it a masterpiece or anything like
that still it's a show that leaves a
strong impression a visible impact in
the audience's heart i sure didn't
expect something of this quality when i
first saw the previews
next is tomodachi game
entering the season i felt that this
would be one of the cult classics of the
season i know it won't be a super
mainstream hit but with its overall
themes and ambience i feel that it will
garner a niche yet passionate fan base i
guess it also helps that other non-anime
media such as squid game became hits not
so long ago not to say that they're the
same but the somewhat similar vibes will
make some people check this one out
there's also danganronpa so yeah the
story beats are quite predictable to
some people but that doesn't make
thomadachi game any less entertaining
for me it didn't bother me that much and
i felt that the twists and turns the
story took are quite enjoyable i
personally have a great time whenever i
get to see the main character show off
his skills and tactics what started out
to be a series of games ended up being
more complex and compelling as they go
on and it always leaves an air of
mystery in its wake domadachi game is
one of the most promising hits of the
season but i think that it's also
something that lends itself to being
niche in the world of anime
next is shikimori's not just a cutie
[Music]
slice of life isn't typically the genre
that i look out for immediately when
looking at the seasonal charts but after
finding myself so enthralled by dress-up
darling last season i'm definitely up
for more naturally shikimori looks to
build on that momentum of playing guy
having misadventures with a cute and in
this case cool and badass partner
shikimori is not just a cutie finds
itself to be one of those slice of life
shows that tried to bring something new
to the table and succeed at it while
it's nowhere near the top of the charts
and shikimori and izumi don't quite
capture the magic marion and gojo bought
is still a very cute and entertaining
watch the show puts a lot of its eggs in
the production basket as it looks very
clean vibrant and refreshing perfect for
the kind of mood that the show has going
for it if you like something new out of
the slice of life genre complete with
pretty visuals shikimori must make it to
your seasonal watch list
[Music]
you
[Music]
when i compared shikimori with dress-up
darling i think the aharen can be
compared to tanaka remember that show or
maybe a bit of gamisan if you want
something more modern it's another odd
couple rom-com that in its way brings
something partially new to the table i'm
mainly talking about the emphasis on the
dynamic between aharen and raido it's
something that doesn't come up often and
i think that it's your reception of such
dynamic which will determine how much
you'll enjoy aha son it's one of those
shows that produces a lot of its
comedies through various mishaps and
misunderstandings also exaggerated
reactions and assumptions there are a
lot of laughs to be had and a whole load
of jokes thrown your way in this
charming rom-com it's not the most
original thing out there but it tries to
stand out and do its own thing probably
the most quirky fluffy show in the
season if you get what i mean
but hey in order to get up to speed with
the latest anime we all have our
streaming sites to thank for that but
what about the older ones the ones that
haven't gotten their licenses renewed
but where do i start and how do i get
the best deal on those that's where our
sponsors of this video slick deals come
into play slick deals is a browser
extension that acts as an aggregator to
compare and contrast prices of products
online it gives an overall view of the
prices of products and informs you about
possible promos and discounts in order
for you to get the best possible deal
plus it also has this cool function that
automatically looks for coupons so keep
those discounts coming
and it doesn't just stop with anime you
can get your fair share of video games
appliances gaming peripherals and loads
more that way i could get your money's
worth when looking for anime movies and
series the other thing i love about
sleek deals so much is how community
oriented it is prices get updated in
real time thanks to its ever active
community with tens and thousands of
customers that way you can always
guarantee to get the best prices even as
the market shifts if you're someone who
remotely enjoys online shopping slick
deals is here for you beat the game in
the world of online shopping and make
the most out of your opportunities with
slick deals download it through the link
in the description box
[Music]
it seems that the way for a new overlord
season has grown the appetite for more
shows like it so we've got skeleton
knight in another world people have
compared the two and some have even
called this show overlord with a more
heroic protagonist with that comes a
story that has an overall lighter tone
it's faster paced and the world building
while good isn't quite as intricate as
i'd have wanted still it's a fun and
enjoyable watch if you're up for some
isakai it's not super unique or anything
like that but as a show it's possible
and enjoyable mainly due to the
familiarity of all the attractive
designs for the characters also can i
just talk about how he had such a banger
of an op i've been a pelican fan for
almost a decade now and it's wholesome
to see him make it
[Music]
before we hit the last three let's look
at our washi
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been a while since i've felt so
good about an up and coming sports anime
but oh she just hits all the right notes
for me i don't know i guess it's just
because the more polished and
professional setting of it all gone were
the high school clubs and the magical
powers and moves not that i find
anything wrong with that of course it's
just that i feel it's nice to take a
break from the haikus and kurokos
occasionally even though i do like those
shows i guess that's why awashi clicks
for me being someone who has an interest
in actual football i like how the show
emphasizes the leagues and actual
strategies it's got a combination of
sports action and drama and comparing it
with the manga i'd say that the anime
does a great job translating the key
moments and emotions from paper to
screen it's also got a good balance
between the sports segments strategies
planning and such with the actual story
at hand which isn't shabby at all if
you're someone with a large amount of
passion for football in real life our
washi is worth a try you'll find it to
be a welcome change of pace from the
usual sport shonen shows and it's super
relatable
now this is a show that completely flew
under my radar in the preseason preview
who knew that a story about a
reincarnated chinese general trying to
fit in with the modern era would be so
entertaining i know manga readers did
but this was a case of not judging a
book by its cover your boy kong ming's
strength comes from how lovable the
characters are kong ming's bond with iko
carried the series for me and is due to
the combination of his wacky way of
applying his centuries-long wisdom in
strategy as well as eco being such a
great protagonist to root for it's a
plucky underdog story but with its own
unique comedic flair i expected your boy
kong ming to be a fun comedy with an
underdog plot after looking at the
previews but never did i expect it to
grip me this much to make me feel for
the characters this much and root for
them as if i had real stakes to me
that's one of the hallmarks of great
anime
[Music]
let's move on to summertime render
mode
i've got an appetite for time loop
stories summertime render exists this
season to satisfy that appetite and when
i had a great time reading it in manga
form i didn't expect the transition to
anime form to be this good just like
when i was reading the manga i truly
sense the air of mystery as the
revelations start coming one by one in
fact some of those things that make
mysteries work are magnified due to the
presence of sound and visuals in the
anime form i already know where the
story's headed but that didn't detract
me from enjoying the series one bit
everything is just so on point and i
like how the show maintains tension
through its presentation it's too bad
that the show is in disney jail that
leaves some very inconsistent release
schedules making discussions quite hard
to come by unlike the other seasonals it
may not have the power to move
communities like re zero or arrays did
the summertime render takes the concept
of those shows and pushes even further
somewhat under disgust and as
unfortunate as it was it's not the fault
of the show
[Music]
surprise surprise spy family's at the
top of our list
[Music]
so unless you've been living under a
rock or just not gotten involved in
online anime communities in the past few
weeks you all know how big of an impact
spy family has had everyone can't get
enough of it and it's by far the most
popular anime of the season many
consider it anime of the season already
well for me i mean i won't be crowning
the absolute best anime of the season
just yet but it does make a very strong
case and that lies in the enjoyment
factor the show's not a masterpiece in
the literary or critical sense of the
word it doesn't have all those
multi-layered stories that are full of
drama or symbolism but it doesn't need
to it's a comedy and its greatest
strength is pushing the right buttons
and being over the top in the proper way
to create a show that's so immersive
despite its absurdity spy family is one
show that's quite wholesome yet full of
madness and wackiness that you'll only
ever see in anime it's not afraid to be
very expressive and it does such a great
job in exploring family dynamics you can
feel for the characters and you can't
help but root for the makeshift family
to succeed in their daily trials
[Music]
now then is spy family also your best
new anime this spring season or is it
something else i want to see your list
so go ahead and make your voices heard
in the comments section comments are
good for the algorithm and they help me
get in touch with you more you can also
leave some recommendations of lists that
you'd like me to put out in the future
if you prefer using social media however
don't forget to drop by the vinitube
discord you can also support the channel
through patreon for me to make even
better videos for you in the future i
hope you enjoyed that video and i hope
that i was able to find some new anime
for you to watch see you again stay
awesome
you